greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by my bookie let me tell you something
the first weekend of the NC double-a
tournament is the greatest betting event
of the [ __ ] year whether you like
still in our brackets picking the
national champion predicting the first
round upset so all the above my bookie
is the perfect home for your March
Madness fun I'll tell you what I'm gonna
do this is the church family you're
gonna get a $50 deposit with my bookie
today with promo code Church CH you are
CH a 50% signing bonus you understand me
you start off the bat with if you put a
yardstick boom you got a yard and a half
now ready to bet [ __ ] all the teams
that's promo code Church CH you are CH
with my bookie you play you win you get
paid listen real quick is one of my
favorite [ __ ] companies in the world
because they put out the device that's
gonna save your [ __ ] life okay uncle
Joey's here to tell you don't cut your
dick off the suffering ends now with
manscape you can get it done without the
pain they got precision listen to me
precision tools for the family jewels
you don't want nothing [ __ ] nicking
your nutsack even go down on the chicken
she's got those little knickers on the
side and next thing I got yeah you like
a little red thing on your face
people could suck your dick with
confidence I got a hell a handheld razor
with skin-safe technology so I won't
snag lists or Nick your ball sack with a
[ __ ] stick of debt you gotta go easy
on that [ __ ] pole of debt so listen
they got that crap preserver
they got the Reviver they got a ball
wipe that you can wipe your ass to it
don't just save it for your balls flip
it over get 2 uses out of one do me a
favor the church listeners go to get 20%
off your first order when you use promo
code church at manscape calm again
that's manscape calm and if you order
the perfect package also throw in a free
[ __ ] travel bag which is bad to
the bone I had in my suitcase when you
use code
Church CH you are CH that's manscape
calm
use promo code church for 20% off your
first daughter keep your balls clean
it's that [ __ ] you're getting ready
for next Valentine's Day and never
forget my favorite on it on it
iseman Haysom the shrimp that you see
lead qualified and second I flew last
week why I take immune tak shoot a
commune that's the best thing go you're
on a plane with a bunch of [ __ ]
foreigners and half-breeds you got to
protect yourself
yeah I'm saying it if not you gotta wear
a [ __ ] mask [ __ ] that gotta calm
right now
pressing code charge and get 10% off
your [ __ ] all to kick this
[ __ ] mule eat this [ __ ] Jam kills
you know right now it don't [ __ ] with me
but now at this age you hear this you're
like [ __ ] whenever I look at mercy well
I hear these words I kind of [ __ ] me I
get it yeah I was just in Colorado
leaving a prison I was minding my own
business
I lit up in the blink of a [ __ ] eye
what's going on my fast man I'm doing
good it was great to see you last night
fun night this house on fire last
[ __ ] Josh punky I mean it was just
great to see the fresh faces of me yeah
let me see you back there [ __ ] Hall
and B is his [ __ ]
that woman they just come up doing all
it's you shot yep you never [ __ ] know
you're back there washing dishes yeah
and they came up to him and then he came
on I tried to get the Chinese can't get
on offing Charlie Fung child chowman or
the board that I love them so much and
he's like no he's not a regular don't
put him up yeah you know he was Sydney
goes thank you but they won't pump me up
it'll pay right how are you gonna do but
see him punky and Josh just earlier in
the night Lucas roll one up and ripped
it too
Lucas is dead yeah it was great it's
weird when you see these people you came
up with not Lucas don't look I hate kids
now the bartender okay the other kid
looks like Opie what up dude yeah he did
great he losing my all apart get out of
here yeah did schraeder I didn't know
that yeah he moved then he always tells
me if I had coke fall in the wall one
night and Terry was up and I'm trying to
figure out how I'm gonna gonna bust that
wall wait how did that happen yeah cuz I
went to hide it I used to have a hiding
spot above the leg like if you if any of
them that whole apartment had molding
around the door around the door okay so
on top of every molding was always
something a straw so
just in passing I could just lift my
hand up grab a straw right from if I
need it when I would have something on
every mold me in that apartment a half a
gram would blow a gram blow something I
had him in all those ledges there was
times I wasn't looking for blow and I
would find blow Wow
but I never found blow after I quit I
was just gonna ask you never found I
don't think so
I know what I did one time it's like
some loss I never really found [ __ ] well
it was over it was over it was the Lord
what a blasted [ __ ] that's a blast one
time I was in [ __ ] all the while and
abrasca driving back from Detroit mm-hmm
I was doing a [ __ ] no Theory nighter
in Dearborn Michigan and some broken on
the car the axis in the backseat and
Here I am with all the while Nebraska
and as they a girl job because a gas
station and a [ __ ] guy told the car
and there was a hotel right next to the
[ __ ] kinda stan has a miracle from God I
had $48 I had just gotten paid I didn't
have the 48 and a 90 for the tire mm-hmm
but this is this is what happens on the
road this money was going somewhere else
but now well I'll never forget I was ice
blue a Chinese food in that car
Wow traced him way out coking there from
time to time and one night I lost some
coke in there and Here I am and all the
while Nebraska and I'm getting all the
quarters out and getting the rolling
papers because I won't have the car from
the whole day yeah and something made me
look under the seat and there's a
[ __ ] statue of a rock that had been
there for like a month I rock the coke
just under my see that would be like a
gram but I have I took that [ __ ]
put in my little pocket oh the law was
tremendous definitely I don't know what
the [ __ ] I ate when you find shits a
surprise you know like it was that's the
last time I got surprised
it's like find the money in an old
jacket or something you're like yes oh
my god such a good feel one time I was
in the Jersey Shore and one of us had to
go home to get more money like we're
just tapped out it's Thursday and the
weekend was coming nobody had [ __ ]
money all right
and I go let me jump in the ocean I take
the bus ride up was I gonna have a nap
bus ride I jump in the ocean I popped my
head up and out they're always coming at
me a bill and when I went to scape it I
was a little bit oh my god
there was a lot of bill nobody went down
the shore we got hot roast beef
sandwiches we Swiss cheese on this one
the boardwalk ah it's great when you
find something like that when I find the
dollar I'm happy yeah it makes makes I
found a dime when you got to put
whatever I put changing the meter I
always find chains on the floor that's
right especially like the Sherman Oaks
people don't get before yeah yeah well
corner don't give a [ __ ] what's going on
with your wife brother life's pretty
good Joey what did you give up on sugar
really yeah I just made sure I would eat
fish
every Friday like I do I don't give
nothing up I just give up [ __ ] meat
on Fridays and it helps me yeah it makes
you a little more conscious yeah you
know what I mean every Friday I get LOX
and bagels well that's nice that's
what's good about life they always got
to get the locks on Friday well yogurt
with fruit yeah well yo good I haven't
had my fillet of fish yet I do that once
every went on a Friday to remind me what
it was like to be a little kid Luther's
grab a shamrock shake and a fillet of
fish oh oh seven years old I don't what
are you looking after I get I wouldn't
have the shamrock shake now but no I get
the [ __ ] the one that you take all I
mean I'm white trash - yeah I love fish
anything yeah I get the Gordy's ah
the fish sticks fish tank so I wife was
like what the [ __ ] was he I break down
like yeah box of fish sticks and that
make it get that [ __ ] macaroni salad
but they make a Gelson to talk I can't
make the dick in this town nothing
nothing I like we live in Los Angeles
well you think it would be more diverse
is she like that now even the barbecue
place I was going to I thought what the
Houston last week you know I guess what
other place the case like I'm not going
there no more no [ __ ] how many
Houston a Papa does get the ball without
your seafood gumbo for 12 they want 21
21 dollars for a bowl of gumbo I'm not a
cheap dude man but this is a principle
involved it's a principle there's
something about and you go there and
it's never done on time
the brisket was okay last when I went
the some people's house whose mercies
friend yeah real cool bow it's really
[ __ ] cool parents and they said we
wanted to fool you guys hungry you know
is a the quantity how eat something and
they go this like the best barbecue
place to Valley oh my god that's why I
[ __ ] for that well hello Natasha flarm
times to it I woke up this [ __ ] dripping
down right after four [ __ ] shits I
took the brisket just tasted like pot
roast huh but barbecue sauce on the
macaroni and cheese they used noodle
macaroni ah tries make [ __ ] crazy
already the beans tasted like somebody
[ __ ] don't mic door for him ah
the chicken was okay it was men's I'm
bollocks but it wasn't barbeque chicken
just plain smoked yeah it's it's so
weird when people think oh you must lead
people were very impressed with the
green apple that day yeah pea-brain
Apple press that night I have a couple
people coming twice since your birth
since people were really impressed with
it not a bad but you know again it's
Chinese and you have to restrict
yourself like what to get in there
because yeah got it were certain things
off the menu expand do certain things
and I guess I haven't um every time
what's that - haven't checked it was
like an odd slice pin chicken somebody's
cat you could feel the cuts of the meat
and they little mushrooms on like a
light little white sauce I'll get
broccoli I don't eat the broccoli I just
get there I get steamed rice I just got
a cup of rice it's not bad yeah not like
fried rice is where you want to go
overboard you might as well get the
dumplings case nothing brings you back
with the garlic fried rice a couple that
is eight points yeah a couple regular
rice is like six so there's really no
different came out he'll go and enjoy it
so enjoy and it's garlic so you've not
even meat and there's a lot of
vegetables are there so it's really just
plain rice that's killing you well the
carbs in the right and that ying-ying
sauce they cooking it because that
shit's got a lot of sugars that's what
you gather that's what has and what it's
all deep-fried all the stuff I like
Steve so wisely I bombed it the Steve at
the store and I was talking about this
Jim I saw I'm not looking to join gyms
or nothing like that but this concept
was very good mmm
what is it circuit training and you
could go in at you
convenience so I was driving the other
night and I saw it like all wow that I
was at a light and then on that strip is
health strip in Sherman Oaks yep it's
[ __ ] every two things it's something
about how y'all go well I guarantee
they're banging you out for thousands up
there cuz it's Sherman Oaks yeah so I
got home the babysitter's dad we're
talking trying on the living room they
don't know computer room and just look
at the website for this great [ __ ]
what they're doing is great I looked up
the benefits mm-hmm the people over 50 I
have read about this stuff before that
hit training yeah will you go all out
for three minutes then you rest for a
minute
yeah alone for three minutes and you
just do like nine stations and the 30
second the breather is an active so you
never just standing okay you're always
doing something light photo sturdy so it
burns a lot of fat that's good for
people over 50 yeah and it's really good
for cardio really lifts your cardio from
point A to point Z so I go let me go
down and check it out sadly my day got
too late but yesterday son that goes
well now that the girls were in church
and I went down apple and here's the
thing guys you have this number one
absolutely not your health you really
can't [ __ ] do dick you know you're
immobilized to do stand-up and to do it
successfully every week you know every
other week and to be on your feet for
long periods of time lots of work
catches it's a workout when you get back
to your room come be like God why am I
so hungry and low points left yeah and I
got a dip into the [ __ ] other points
I got laughing why am I so hungry but
they don't have Stanley you can't really
measure what you're burning out stage
during stand-up comedy you just know you
get back to your room your exhaust your
thought to exhaust it you're on the
source side you know do you ever wear a
heart rate wire on stage yeah see why
would I do something like that boy a
heart rate monitor real [ __ ] life
okay well going deep the lay low we feel
I should have [ __ ] got yeah I tried
to spare you but I think it's time for
you to do the pill time you need
something sure why not
it's Monday what the [ __ ] what else
you do with your life you got nowhere to
go tonight No
be open mic action and [ __ ] go down
there you'd be a little higher your bump
the levels a little high
sure you need something sure you should
go ahead to be it's all gone and four
okay
please happy the agent made you shave
yeah he said he'll younger he said I
could do more so we'll see what happens
here
sure so good excu told mother's name too
now all of a sudden I knew I knew that
we don't tell you the shame I've been
here for 20 [ __ ] years waiting they
tell you I was done with you for the
first time and what he had to get like a
little mustache I think I'm the NBC show
no there's the mustache no figure it out
that's [ __ ] weird when I tell you
what kind of haircut to get that was
atheist I would go [ __ ] yeah go [ __ ] you
see yeah I don't want to work that you a
dog three shots
oh yeah do you have a tennis racket take
it was a family man listen just get use
that hecha at the job you gotta get and
going will you [ __ ] it's all kickbacks
right like they get kickbacks from the
photography stuff like that photographer
in the hole turns and they have the
things that you have to join up for yeah
you know they have all these little
packages that you have to join to get
seen you know yeah job and that though
that's not free either no and you gotta
take this class I need you to take a
commercial acting class they get a
kickback from that I gotta kick back
from that but you know what listen I'd
rather you walk in there with a
direction you're never gonna put
together an audition on your own mm-hmm
it's you have to go a little you have to
go to them and get burnt you have to go
to them and go why am I going yes and
then one day clicks and you take a call
reading workshop and you keep going and
then you're getting close meaning
callbacks you got a pin in yeah but
you're not booking
Dan you fit in that time you figure out
how to incorporate your standing up into
that audition
yes so now you take it back to Mitzi
shore why does she make you do three
minutes spots yep to teach you have a
light up a room in three and three
minutes everybody'll say I can't do it
it's too hard
[ __ ] you you
have to learn how to do you have to
learn how to do three minutes because
she's trimming the fat off you yeah so
you know how to make your presentation
in three minutes
yeah how long is the audition 3 for 6
minutes depending on where you take it -
yeah you could go in there read it once
and they'll say very nice - thank you
and thank you have a great thank you
have a great day you know or you could
work with them let's read it one more
time give me a little attitude okay I
got a hook somewhere some I did that I
got an are you writing the way but
you're not gonna learn that in two days
now to learn that whatever to manage
you're not an agent that's patient yep
that gets you out a couple times yeah
commercial with a [ __ ] [ __ ] the
Booker come on that's why it's so easy
to get a commercial agent yes they know
they know that a [ __ ] if you got a
missing eye that might be what they're
looking for that money would get you the
job look at the book all you have to do
is you'll go to that book store in the
book Samuel French and your fridge
closing yeah that one's closed yeah it's
about to close yeah well they have a
book called AIDS it's commercial agent
yeah and when you open it they'll tell
you what every agency is looking for
comedians
yeah what they specialize in and stuff a
lot of these was there that's right
that's like God one day I was stoned
this [ __ ] and I was read those books and
while the agency said they're looking
for puppeteers know one of the guys on
stilts still Walker yeah yeah call the
agent Walker I got a couple jobs I just
have my guy told me right out he's like
the only other fat guy I have has red
hair and it makes him look kind of scary
so I think I can do a lot with you look
like okay
that's what you know that's what you was
I I think Lee's gonna book like crazy
yeah I think you look like crazy the
right thing has to I mean it's got to be
the right fastball well see he keeps
saying he's gonna set me up for TV and
come and movies do I just let me live in
your guest house when you buy your
estate of course I would love to live
with you know it's it's us the TV
commercial and the commercial the TV
audition the commercial edition
yep that's a really hard one to crow
it's really hard to cross that bridge
you have to you know I finally came to
it I finally surrendered and said stand
up isn't [ __ ] coming my way I better
learn this acting game a little bit yeah
so I got involved you could open up the
doors okay jump it it's [ __ ] hot it's
a beautiful day it's been [ __ ]
gorgeous in Los Angeles the last five
[ __ ] days has been have you dressed
and said I dressed too hot to go out yes
week Oh yesterday ok I'm going home I'm
taking a shower on to this I'm throwing
on short a light [ __ ] shirt that's it
we're in season again it's great what
straight seasons Oh goodbye at night
it's a little [ __ ] cool but it's
perfect I love it so we were talking
about this this place I want it so again
I like this cell I like to be sold
I would sell people mm-hmm when I go
into your spot whether it's buy a stereo
something that had that contact with you
mm-hmm
I want you to sell me oh I would sell
you and I'll give you whatever you ask
for it if you could tell they really
care I'm gonna [ __ ] with you a little
bit give you two why I have a money you
know like this place yesterday when I
went in there right they wanted a
certain fee 180 a month and Bonnie
dollars to to uh let's say you have to
travel they shut the account down fee
it's $20 to open and reopen or Bali [ __ ]
the Bali technology you had to buy that
glove you had a button I'm very happy at
my place but I wanted to see what they
had going on yeah
and it was so weird that the guy sat me
down and he was like this is what we do
here but the yardstick includes now
first of all I knew that he like he
wasn't the boss okay so I would still
have to get approved so humbling
I was taken Li going back to on Tuesday
and just torturing her just to say how
sign up cash but no [ __ ] waive their
annual fee yeah because they want an
initiation with ian gerrie go it's not
worth it to me
it's too much money but 280 is a lot
honey man I don't sign that on shoe jets
unless you're a [ __ ] world-class
athlete it's going in there five days
going in there five six seven days a
week
alas not that it really doesn't I don't
need that much attention I already know
what I'm doing those but I love where I
go I love the conditioning over there I
love the conditioning classes I love the
jujitsu program
I love the Muay Thai I was just checking
out what was out there yeah you know I
love I love where I left where I left I
love it too nice and easy quick yeah and
you're out of there no drama clean how
much is that every month I think it
comes out the way I paid her to $77 a
session or something okay weird thing
but it's either working like one-on-one
with a trainer yeah for seven that's a
waste
she racks the weight she does everything
I don't even know what I'm lifting
that's great she has the stop time when
she's got the [ __ ] pencil everything
that's done by science she sends me an
email the next week of what I did the
week before I wouldn't love you know a
place like that I didn't do I plateauing
on my chest but my legs I improved 8%
that's correct sir I have been you know
at this age I've been really from what I
talked to Dolce yeah what I've spoken
the guy's expert he's all about like
people who train people yeah is that I'm
trying to look through what's the most
beneficial in the time that I have yeah
okay I will never work out at night I
lose my focus at night you'll call me
ten times use your right hand use your
right hand after three o'clock 2:30 my
[ __ ] is bad like that like yeah my
alertness is from [ __ ] six to one
maybe two after that I can't it throws
everything off yeah everything is thrown
off that's why I try to find the program
I could go right in the morning without
procrastinate that's the secret that's
the secret I don't even want to think
about it nine o'clock kickboxing yeah it
was perfect for me yep there's no
procrastinate I got mercy boom she
leaves I jump in the shower and next you
know I want the [ __ ] door to go kick
box yeah
there's no procrastination whatsoever I
don't have to wait till three is six
you know I'm not gonna go off all the
work
all apart I don't even like to think on
the days where I'm going to jujitsu
where it's just like okay I gotta wake
up and just go cuz I'll talk myself out
yeah you told you so far riding yeah
yeah that's why I always do someone
Monday if you don't do something on
Monday today I already [ __ ] worked
out already
yeah if you don't do something on Monday
you're behind it the Apple yeah
something happened out whose day is the
biggest audition there there is if you
look at your [ __ ] schedule over the
years you realize that Tuesday is always
the beginning of the casting session
okay it's the first couple characters
then they call you back Thursday and you
shoot in a week and a week and a half
I'm kind Tuesdays a big audition day
that's why I don't like Tuesday
activities I want to get my work and out
[ __ ] done Monday morning at least one
I gotta jump now if something happens to
is that I got Wednesday so that means I
got to before I went on the road yeah
I'm definitely gonna [ __ ] lift one of
those so I got a lift in there if I go
to a hotel room and they got weights
I'll do the weights if not you can walk
on the treadmill on the treadmill the
elliptical or I'll go to a kickboxing
gym like the you find those on the road
yeah oh that's great look on over I see
what is the difference with the hotel if
it's more than 20 I want to go to guys
too far it's too far for me it's gonna
be 40 minutes out of my way
but if I do break this says [ __ ]
democracy I'm done it you know I'm down
I'll call the hotel with ask them where
the nearest kickboxing gym did before I
got on the plane I always had never done
I really want to learn those mighty low
kick it's interesting because I learned
something Roach could always fly in one
night earlier and he had the internet
Rogan always had the Internet mmm-hmm
but Rogan had a [ __ ] system that was
brilliant
he's a gene he's gone out this like I
see and ask him what's the best
restaurant in town can he go there
with the four of us we eat and he tip
out 300 bucks
Wow you know how fast that word gets out
yeah take Brogan's in town so meanwhile
you're paying for [ __ ] Facebook ad
just go to the baddest restaurant in
town yeah at about a hundred to two
people's like Sinatra Sinatra yeah and
the next day at the [ __ ] show people
were there wow that were at the
restaurant the word gets out they go out
you know there's a bar staff yes the
cool cats what people yeah they go out
of ten they go to a bar
afterward the city starts on jump off
you and I start talking and there's no
better word than word of mouth it's
quicker than [ __ ] anything it's
quicker than anything guess who is that
the palm here that Steve some oh it's
such a so you could look at it two
different ways I look at it as going to
kickbox like I don't want to [ __ ] eat
a steak at 10 o'clock at night I don't
give a [ __ ] when I'm gonna kick box you
take a picture with the guys there yeah
no point they asked our telling friends
all their friends it's the same
psychology you know I'm saying you have
a good time and you work out and they'll
I'm the way home they'll give you a
Reynold weed yeah yeah don't have weed
Kansas City Zak's gym they were [ __ ]
great people when I go to Columbus
that's a great gym hope yeah crew hope
is [ __ ] phenomenal you know when I go
out but Kirk can't go to Winkeljohn Wow
and he taught me a little bit I did the
podcast yeah yeah so they're into you
coming in that's when I go to Jersey
they always taught me to come to that
one jujitsu place but they gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of me when I go to the
stress factory yeah and New Brunswick
they have the East Brunswick Academy I
think that's what Gary told is that all
those killers they move break your legs
they like that my life but they want you
to come back yeah do you have C gym that
closed the Fairview that was my home
away from home
Wow because the UFC gyms are [ __ ]
phenomenal I've never been in one a UFC
gym has something going on there we have
something that you like that you can do
that's awesome that you don't need a
gear or nothing like that
they starts at 6:00 and they go to like
3 in Fairview they have like a strength
and poly metric class where you get up
on boxes you hit a speed bag I love
doing all that different stuff you're
inspired just to get you a little
yeah listen you're still gonna get your
two hours of riding and you're still
gonna watch your show on Netflix
you're still gonna take a nap but it's
just nice like I was telling somebody
when I travel I don't like to eat I'm
like a morton's or a [ __ ] popular
place I want some of the city's Flair oh
that's my favorite I always ask for tips
of you whenever I don't good good I'll
tell you yeah I can tell you they'll
tell you what's good and then you see
what like the you know ten people tell
you one place for people tell you know
and four people tell you another then I
decide by what's the closest okay I'm
wearing there's not gonna be a line yes
what's the easiest if I'm gonna go the
other side of town I got a way to no
that's not where you're famous now
that's an hour they're like barbecue
places in Texas we're gonna pay somebody
to wait in line yeah go around the donor
there's no line in 90% is good I'll put
those across the street and they'll hit
the poor exacto well hey don't worry
about not another one again no car would
that's right exactly
I'm gonna gather it here I still write
some kind so gave me a [ __ ] free
dinner for two to Chuy's I got the
coupon on my desk example bar when I go
in Dallas Oh
San Antonio hopefully somebody's got a
[ __ ] Chuy's I don't know and I got to
[ __ ] business already that's a very
well that [ __ ] I love all that [ __ ]
those little jumps you know you have to
do something when you travel a lot yeah
you know I mean you go on those road
trips at Ari well they go ski in this
[ __ ] Wow I don't do any of that
I just go to hang out with the guys I
don't know how to ski I don't know did
you go this last time no any good
cuz I like he brought me the first
couple times he started to do it and was
great just to hang out and I've laughs
but I am first off it's gonna cost you
five six hundred dollars just to get
this stuff like he'll work out trait but
I gotta get a lesson now I tried the
snowboard once I fell so hard I'm not
making I heard people scream in three
different languages at once well that's
a true story I was going down the bunny
hill on a snowboard I felt my pack so
hard I split my jacket like I flat on my
back and at the same time I heard like
oh my god deals meals and then I heard
she's out
and I was at I was like that is there
was I took the board off and I went back
to the thing and I there was no bigger
addiction I had this game how did you
learn how to do it you believe that it
was one of those things where when I
came from Cuba
my favorite James Bond movie was Her
Majesty's Secret Service okay
when I first saw people skiing I lost my
mind and then I had a weight weight and
then I became like this half a criminal
and then when I was 18 or 19 one of my
friend said to me that he had a a thing
to go skiing at the Playboy Resort in
Pennsylvania so like up in the poke and
I was really fun for the Poconos it was
like 10 o'clock skiing mm-hmm and I
didn't think about anything I didn't
know the variables of what was involved
yeah I don't know that the Sun Goes Down
you know you forget all those things now
when you're outside it yes and I'll
never forget getting on that [ __ ]
thing and it being just freezing that's
the part I don't like the call reowing
that's why I moved here then when they
dropped you off it wasn't like I didn't
know what it was at that time but it was
just a sheet of ice that you were gonna
break your [ __ ] neck oh yeah I'm
gonna forget I'm not ashamed to say this
I made them take me down in the [ __ ]
sleep yeah I'm not doing I swear to God
yeah I don't play 18 I made them take me
down on the snow I probably I was 17 I'm
harder to get I came with the gondola or
whatever this scheme yeah yeah i sat
there I looked down there was a breeze
like a wind yep yeah I was like no just
have like a [ __ ] this is you know I
didn't understand anxiety I didn't
understand breathing and like it was all
too fast for me yep I looked down I saw
that hell I saw ice yeah forget it I was
like I'm not doing this and I told the
guy I can't do this yeah some of the
people laughed at me on the first I felt
I was in shape I had like a hooded
[ __ ] sweatshirt on oh my god
and they ski guard came over yeah moved
the skis the guy was pissed
he was like you didn't you're gonna try
and I'll [ __ ] lose it and they put me
in the back of the thief like I hadn't
fallen off yeah he dragged me like
[ __ ] idiot thought I was and I went
back to the [ __ ] hotel room and
snorted coke with
yeah I don't blame her they forgot about
it after like a month and nobody told me
I was a [ __ ] no more and then I moved
to Colorado and I we get there in my
[ __ ] job and look at people come down
this hill yeah and people go don't you
ski now it just being negative you know
I was just a kid not all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] ski I you know anyone what the
[ __ ] is what are you saying Joey you
know I only [ __ ] skis the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] sport look at them out there
freezin yeah who would wanna freeze and
more more people I'd see them come off
the hill
maybe happy that they'd be refreshed yes
that [ __ ] red-eyes [ __ ] yeah but they
would tell me how that weed smoking pot
I mean mushrooms I'm like that's uh
that's okay and then the guy I was
robbing I thought it was big and I had
my 20 30 K put away and he put away at
blow put away jewelry put away however
you this is I was late teen 1983 I'm
weddy class 20 and I was living in
Snowmass Village I had worked on a house
with a carpenter mm-hmm and the people
weren't coming home for that winter so I
hit all my cash I had a key and had the
alarm code well I would just go up there
watch TV [ __ ] bring food up there I
got a beautiful house a beautiful home
that they had redone it was for condos
next to each other mom and I would walk
into the water so I put all my stash in
there I guess they raided my house take
then finally they're so smart sometimes
I'm a piece of [ __ ]
I thought I would never know how to do
anything that's him the guy next to me I
lived through the d12 increased side the
guy next to me and em and I became
friends with neighbor for one day like
before Christmas like December 15th
mm-hmm we were talking because my father
died yesterday I don't know if I go I
can't afford it and I thought about my
mother and when I went to the condo and
I just [ __ ] 500 bucks and then I went
back right man I don't really know you
go see your father
Wow go see your father paid me a hundred
a week and you know he's like nobody's
ever done this
justtake they were good guys he was from
like Minneapolis or something but he was
also the general manager sport Caleb
okay sport Kalyn was the big ski shop up
there the best one like the best that's
we knew whether you were filthy rich got
you what the sport came when he came
back he gave me like 250 cuz my mother
gave me money
take this 250 and I'll pay a hundred for
two weeks and fifty dollars on he goes
listen I really want what you did for me
English come up and anytime you want to
ski it's on me Wow and at this time me I
go I never skied before and I keep
putting a dime then he goes wrong one of
the best errors on the hill even if I
have to leave that and give me a lesson
wow that's nice and leave there and give
you a quick lesson so Christmas you know
Eve comes and then Christmas Day comes I
got no family
yeah you got a remember up there the
weather is completely different
60 degrees up in Aspen it's completely
different than sixty degrees down here
how so because there's a low moisture
effect so the snow doesn't melt but it
stays warm I don't know if I'm saying it
correctly so it's warmer up there but
it's still snow on the round you go ski
you come down with something yeah in
Colorado when you go skiing and by the
Aspen Snowmass it's beautiful I would go
just for the scene right out there that
Ajax when you love skiing Ajax you do
three runs you come back with some tears
that people want okay like I wouldn't
even wear shields I would yeah I did
wear shield for a while and then
sometimes that my buddy gave me a pair
like combination glasses down a rope on
the back because I didn't like that I
like the sundae I didn't want to have
those raccoon eyes yep
so I went on Christmas Day it had to be
lunchtime 10:30
mmm I was sitting there watching like a
[ __ ] parade like a Momo we had like
maybe 20 channels we had cable and USA
and everything I said you know what what
take his offer up I walked up there at
some burgundy beef at the stewpot which
is three doors down from spoke cab and
walking just more Cameron I'm gonna go
scan and he goes
this way you have had jeans a t-shirt
like a hooded sweatshirt
he's answers well yeah and he just went
got me everything new Wow pants a shirt
the whole [ __ ] thing gloves boots
that demos they would rent skis but he
gave me the good stuff the demos that's
awesome so he would give me like the
people from Texas company all business
and they're gonna spend neither laws for
Prensky boots
yep they don't just give those to
anybody I'm like they would you know if
you come in and drop twenty thousand
with you for four kids how let you do
whatever you want right you know if a
dealership knows you're gonna spend
money and you tell him I want to drive
the car off for a week no give you a
call for a week Wow you get the level
money up there with the level of money
is staggering you know Justin when he
goes you know I saw the level of money
up to age so we're now huh
those homes are five to six million
dollars attended that and also remember
that's somebody's second or third or
fourth or third or fourth that's six
million dollar home they're not even
there mm-hmm
they got a kid for two hundred a week
they pay you know what I would 9600 a
year there's something for somebody to
live in their [ __ ] six million dollar
house yep two bills a week you get and
free rent and you got a shovel
you gotta mow the lawn you're gonna
paint yep you got to make sure
everything's up to par when they come
into town and then when they come into
town you could [ __ ] go you disappear
for three months so you would say your
schedule like that so I will in they put
everything out he goes with some busy
it's Christmas Day so come and meet ya
at the ski lift meet me over at a eight
or something
mmm and I'll give you a quick lesson and
I'll never forget he goes just put the
skis on this ski over to the thing bro
when I went outside he's like he taught
me like a couple things yeah he was all
right you see that blue sign get over
there
show him my past no a child for free Wow
and he goes I gotta go back in and he
went back in you know it took me an hour
get over there yeah falling yeah I
believe it that's why I don't do I
finally took the [ __ ] skis off and I
walked over yeah and walks like I just
landed on the moon I walked over there
put the [ __ ] skis on and I go Jesus
Christ
I'm doing I hope I'm doing the right
thing and ride away when that thing
dropped me off
I didn't land on ice I landed on 24
inches of powder you see your feet just
sinking they just pull yourself and it
was bon voyage like that first thing
going down man pretty scared I was
scared but I was happy that I wasn't
scared
gotcha but now I had to figure something
else out how to stop yeah because he
taught me like the little things out of
plow yeah you put you needs to gain to
slice or whatever they say yeah so I met
him after the first run he goes how you
did it
I was [ __ ] like so high my heart was
beating I could feel air I was hot like
I'm ripping a lot of stuff because my
beat my [ __ ] adrenaline was going
everything was gone he gave me like a
quick lesson I swear to God all on
Christmas Day 1983 that's crying he gave
me like a quickly went up like three or
four times did and he goes I gotta go
back to work you're on your own and I
did like two more and the next day I
went to get up and I stopped right here
I was nineteen wedding on my water fob
with that there was muscles in my leg
like the whole top of my leg and the
whole band and at that time I was
running hit the bag riding a bicycle
that uses complete different muscle
again like three days to get up he got
up the next day mm-hmm and walked around
so I cursed it for a couple days where
he goes every was laughing at me you
went skiing if I thought it was a
[ __ ]
ah that's great it was [ __ ] amazing I
told him the truth he goes come back in
two days and all that stuff is yours but
I said don't even worry about the 250
don't even worry buddy no I'm gonna give
it a go don't worry man I kept that
stuff and I went up there and I knew so
many people in the town that they would
charge me that's great yeah we could
just go up to the top of faraway Road
park your car and walk on there's a
little thing there and you're past the
limit where they check the badges yeah
like all those little local horrible
local tricks so I would go up there
and then I got the job house it and it
was on faraway Road so I already knew
how to ski just my feet right on from
your background
my back dog go right down and mix rather
with regular people and get up to the
thing and then go all the way to the top
I got so it so the whole 83 I skied
every day from January 1st to February
1st have you no idea and never in a
million years when I haven't then you
were as every week there was up to 185
was the whole [ __ ] thing
I was buying goggles I had spotted glove
in it loved it then I went to New York
didn't do it got [ __ ] lived in the
park and went through all that bullsh
with my uncle yeah you know stayed there
and then I came out to Colorado in July
I was back into the San Francisco back
up at Aspen back in power back in
Boulder and what I called my buddy to
check in with me goes bro what are you
gonna do this winter and I don't know he
goes I knocked up my girlfriend we're
moving back to Jersey if you want the
house in job it's no mess it's yours on
this one can you be a guy could be there
two [ __ ] days you just come on up
ain't even tell the owner of the house
wow the owner of the house called with
[ __ ] how's it going like oh this is
Joey this is this I go
Jimmy had to leave I'm his friend from
Jersey I've been here for two months he
was implying not to meet you to get
references to get a deposit from me what
did that guy do what do people do that
have that kind of money he was on the
board of chairman of the board of Friday
it's TGIF right Wow and in the two years
and the year I was there his family he
came once and then his daughters came
once in two years that's how many
properties they have yeah that the girl
told me we go to Italy we skied they
were skiing in Switzerland
Wow like they would ski all over the
[ __ ] world the girls but when I went
back in 86 and 80-85 mm-hmm I went back
in October of 85 and I went right back
then I got a job security at night I did
everything I could so I could ski the
daytime that's what everybody does up
there I could security there's a hotel
mmm and I would pick people up at the
airport at the hotel for the 12 they
gave me a three-mile ski pass I wasn't
gonna go to Aspen an AJAX does too much
man sold those
those days they were transferable so I
have a 1200 for the season give me six
so you wanna make money right from the
bath remodel wouldn't say nothing to you
and I would get up there ten o'clock
eleven o'clock ski [ __ ] till 2:00 2:30
smoke dope take a shower and go to work
that sounds awesome your bed the shape
eat like a savage urine higher altitude
so you burn more yeah your body
naturally burns low is eat like a savage
up there then you get to find you know
you start trading down hotel rooms like
this three hotel rooms gonna shut down
because the Hat is pay for it or
something Simone you got to get mothers
in town
yeah come on over Stamper television of
all you for two days you don't cook they
would work in the top of the hill like I
work at a restaurant selected over a
restaurant and eat on the other that's
great
Lu cessation I loved I skied with with a
cocaine habit I never did cocaine ski
like nas my god it was my release from
the drugs but from 85 I skied that whole
season and the beginning of 86 and then
I left Aspen and it broke my heart like
that was that was I didn't work out
all I did was ski just had fun I had a
nuff I didn't even have a punching bag
at that time no didn't even have a
punching bag I just skied but it's so
weird how I tell people once I moved to
Boulder I'd started dating this girl
mm-hmm in 91 led to come and I tried to
do that five in the morning meet and
drive to uh Snowmass and ski I that was
I was done already I'm a man of
simplicity yeah what side if I have to
drive three hours that's not skiing for
me yeah like that's not fine because if
you if I this was like when I saw Ari
last year wouldn't he break his foot he
recently broke he broke his wrist broke
his wrist he brought he's broken
something almost every year every ski
trip the reason that's why that's
another reason why I'm like I'm it's
like not that I love skiing but the
reason the problem is that Ari if you
live in LA you have to go up here once a
week
in ski [ __ ] okay like Big Bear or
sometimes yeah because this is the deal
if I say to you right now no matter how
much money we have if I go to a I'm
taking you the ad Snowmass Village
available to ski or whatever the [ __ ]
the ski you haven't done it a year yeah
so first of all you have one natural
enemy as soon as you get to little ski
resorts that's called the [ __ ] uh the
altitude altitude yeah that's it
so whatever when I perform at the Comedy
Works yeah because I have no mic oh I
need to drink some water I need to sit
on the stool there's no edibles the
first couple days it's not because you
don't know when you might bend over yep
all it takes is a bend over when you
holding your breath and you go to graph
and your mind not getting among oxygen
offs in your mind spins out you get
[ __ ] anxiety it happened but I
fainted up there first time I did a bong
it you can't so when you go back up
there you have to be in ski shape mmm I
never understood people who go up there
what do you do ski for two days you're
not gonna be able to walk yeah you're
not gonna be able to walk I'm going up
there next year with mercy but I'm gonna
take her up here first yeah get her I'd
sort of reduced like little baby steps
getting ready way she could drive to but
there's a place you could fly to up here
and obviously take a fly up there and
take the plane so she doesn't get
carsick and get her skiing if she adapts
to the ski like if she says daddy this
could be me yeah I would consider moving
to Southern Colorado right now I don't
blame him once I watch Molly's game I
saw the beginning of Molly's games
that's a poker movie yes I haven't seen
at the beginning was she skiing it
brought me back like oh I remember that
yeah that [ __ ] fun like you're
looking at it as a civilian going that
don't look too good no you don't even
feel that cold weather even when she
says it's 14 below with the breeze the
Lord it's not the 14 that people go
through on the East Coast
gotcha see that at sea or you're
changing my whole attitude towards all
of it that's a different 14 it's a
different 14 it's still cold not gonna
take your clothes off and yell Kumbaya
right but it's not what you used to so
that's that's that's why I fight go
skiing that [ __ ] I'm gonna make sure I'm
gonna do it my friend did in Jersey this
year
she went to a ski resort every Wednesday
for a month to prep for a baby so she
could make the most out of the trip
that's smart
cuz I don't drink right I'm gonna be mad
I'm gonna sit in jacuzzis with a bunch
of people with a beer my [ __ ] hair
bright no that [ __ ] appeals to me I'm
gonna [ __ ] ski to get a good vitamin
D Colorado air yeah it's so beautiful up
there so yeah is clean that was clean
like I would just walk around the little
village and then when everybody would
come back I love to hang cuz Ari would
bring just such a good group of people I
was you what is easy
that's how I met Sal Vulcano for
impressionable Joker's Bert Kreischer
you guys this figure he had a good crew
yeah he had a great crew the shot and go
this year but he had like Bert he had a
own Rhino Neil up there it's a lot of
like he got married the so so was either
before his wedding yes I think was right
at wedding or something yeah run is easy
it was up there he's the best
when is easy is the best he really is
but there's nobody more fun than hanging
out with you okay no with the pseudo I
saw him other thing with the pseudo know
he's a it's it's a great thing to ski
I'm happy that I took that part of my
life at that age like I look back and go
who is that guy though how do we get
there yeah same thing from that song
yeah this was beautiful
I was talking to Todd Jordan from Denver
and he asked me yours weren't you a
[ __ ] the dog guy and the comedy works
I had forgotten I was a door guy at
McKelvey's Wow you know one last I have
to see in Josh the door guy got there
grab you a rip it I'm like I remember
being a [ __ ] dog guy doing sound and
I started as a door guy then the sound
guy quit he was too cheap to hire
another sound God since when I was your
new job I would see people and then go
to the south and start to sound but I
would go back to the door throughout
drunk people Wow then the bar back quit
and they said do you want a bar back and
I go [ __ ] yet yeah so they hire the door
guy and I would do the sound and the bar
backing but in the middle of all that I
got into comedy I got on stage that the
Comedy Works and he found out about it
the owner with
and as I was a doorman that would say
wait he said you were doing that before
you were even doing comedy yes the Lord
works in mysterious ways
I got I took the comedy class in January
I didn't have the balls to get on stage
so I got a job at McKelvey's had to be
around the McKelvey's was on the other
side of Denver George McKelvey was a guy
that was in the Tonight Show it he was
the real deal
George McKelvey was a comedian god bless
his soul especially today on st. Patty's
Day and yesterday McKelvey was a guy
that owned the club him and Wendy were
not enemies at all
Oh character Wendy loved George George
just thought that he should own the club
you have been don't come this is the 50s
you know Jackie Gleason why he was an
old-time he might not the best store and
I got into comedy McKelvey had was
already 65 yeah I'm gonna forget he
called me one then only was getting your
car you meet me in Colorado Springs
you're opening up the mere Jeff Valdez
his club tell Judy brundin go [ __ ]
yourself she's gonna try to ask you for
$40 to take a stand-up class you're
waving it we're waving that for you why
me walking in here going oh oh oh you've
never take this for you to perform on
that stage you have to paint Judy Brown
money forty bucks that she would teach a
stand-up for three weeks then you were
prepared to go on the stage so everybody
who worked the club had to go through
that class the cover was like hand paint
he sounds awesome awesome he would drink
I would make him drinks his [ __ ] he
would tell me where to put my jokes so
that's I bet McKelvey's being a dog guy
at with scent because he owned both of
them Wow he was peeled McKelvey's we was
partners on what ten so he had a
guarantee like one appearance a month so
in those four months I was a doorman I
got tight with him no man I was
listening I wasn't going to go into this
without looking over the cliff gotcha so
before I got into comedy I got a job as
a doorman to ask questions
samo telling every here's every week I
asked those comics questions like how do
you do it if you're married whether you
start why do I go there and there was a
couple guys that were really good to me
one guy in particular the name was Reno
good there
mmm-hmm funny guy his closer is the
whole show he does the show and at the
end he rips his wig off he's really both
that's correct he has a toupee that
looks great he just rips it off and
people go crazy he plays the a guitar
standing ovations whole [ __ ] yes
looking at that back there it was very
it was a different act that I wanted
mm-hmm but I saw him kill with that I
standing ovations seven shows you know
people lose them on entertaining so he
helped me in a little bit he told me he
gave me his phone number and he says
called it when you run in tears but what
do you get on stage how old were you
when that's when you started this
process early 2028 Wow
okay was out of prison I got the job as
my first child was born hmm so I got the
job when she was about 10 or 12 months
of about a year old so I had two jobs a
roofer roofing estimator and then at
night from Tuesday to Sunday I would go
home he'd dinner take a shower and shoot
Westminster mom which is before that
wasn't that bad at all right 20 minutes
in those days okay and I would work the
door you know standard one show
Wednesday Thursday to Friday to Saturday
one Sunday and I watched Melissa's and I
asked questions and I read the comedy
newspaper that came every month and you
know before I wanted to jump off the
cliff
and once I was ready I still kept my job
like I was a [ __ ]
mmm-hmm like that was a big-time [ __ ]
I'm not gonna wide anybody didn't tell
you that I did it the right way but I
had to be protected because I I needed
to protect the girl my wife the baby and
yeah inhabit real life so I could just
take a chance just because I wasn't I
was married you know I had a problem I
had somebody who they were they were
from Buffalo you know she was a great
woman she's the reason why I got on
stage but when I was telling that Ricky
Cruz
no I was telling somebody this boy that
you're always gonna be a comedian mm-hmm
if you meet a girl here next year Steve
some oh yeah and you marry and she has
two kids and you're going to move back
to Virginia and you become the king of
Virginia I'm never gonna have a problem
with you I've never had a problem with
you he quit I'm probably you period but
you don't have to live in LA to be a
comedian no I don't cannot people and it
changes even more every year as
technology changes things here I didn't
I I lived in Colorado where nobody knew
you existed there was no YouTube yes
there was no nothing and there was even
a good scene there said I was always
content there was a handful of guys that
have a day job that worked weekends and
they were doing great because then 800
hours is a lot of money that when you're
headlining it's six week I remember
talking to a guy in Indianapolis five
six seven years ago at Christmas he was
making 20,000 in December just doing
Christmas parties and I went I should
just move to another city people don't
understand there's different levels of
comedy
there are a lot funnier comics than what
you people are used to living in
Minneapolis Milwaukee that you'll never
know of because they're in a situation
that they can't get out maybe they
didn't raise the bar that I didn't have
the bar raised that high either yeah
when I first got into comedy it was
gonna be a hobby
some people Bowl some people throw darts
some people [ __ ] you know what's so
funny did I say that - some people where
they go I can't I go look man just do it
if you love it just do it do it if it's
if you really love it's bad yes [ __ ]
butterflies absolutely I'm never gonna
be good at judge itsu but I love going I
love you guys this is great it's a hobby
yeah so when I picked up stand up it was
the night there was no stardom there was
no TV show there was no nothing there
was a group of guys that had to make it
more fun in a way there was a group of
guys that went out of Tuesdays and
Thursday nights to the local open mikes
yeah
you know they had their own room on
Wednesday and every Friday and Saturday
there were in some hellhole in Wyoming
Montana Idaho
you know [ __ ] Utah they were in some
little small town will pay them 800
bucks and on top of the five or four
years ago that's a lot of money you know
they were pain you know you know when
you should worked in Denver you got 50
bucks
whether you feature 25 35 40 but once
you started going into uh you know
Wyoming Riverton working the regional
road working the region a road like
going deep underneath Colorado the
Gunnison where Marilyn was from Colorado
Springs and all that all those one night
is those little savvy aw that adds up so
your hobby is now uh yeah Tuesday and
Thursday you're going up at the bar with
your friends but they give you three
drink tickets right and maybe they give
you a sandwich right now you're going
out you're having laughs and you're not
spending this dino had that room two
years ago in uh yes that's what I'm
looking for yep when you're living in a
place that doesn't have a stage like New
York or LA or Miami never fear you're
still making progress absolutely you
could be making more progress than
people out here absolutely know it
people come here and there's no stage no
stage time so you're making more
progress in one little little town
because you're getting on stage twice a
night four nights a week was Friday and
Saturday it's bad name sorry
yes you know it's bad night that's right
like your schedule will you girlfriend
those are the nights you get a job at a
restaurant as a waiter yeah and then
little by little wait till hey we're
doing Friday night
I got a gig so now after you tell the
restaurant ten times that you can't work
Friday or Saturday they always say
listen you leave this job no more and
you just graduate a level it's so true
now you have to get a [ __ ] comedy gig
on Friday and make up for that but make
up for that [ __ ] money
that's all works it's that's great
Friday and sadly when you an open-mic a
looming in mind there's nothing going on
yeah it's all the paid whatever you
could make it happen you could still go
to a bongo listen what do you do here
after all we do disco at 10:15 you mind
if I go up and do 15 minutes yep it's
the turtle people hit me up on Facebook
I live
with all that [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz I had a
friend named Andy paid and he made gold
on a [ __ ] yep I did economy and all
those beat up boss
all those betta Mitzi told me that Vern
Mitzi told me dice invited her and Argos
wants to go to the movies and before the
movie started dice won and did stand up
in front of the packed movie yeah that's
what you do that states are yep
if you really want to do comedy like you
have to I want you to do it as a hobby
first and here you really feel exactly
if you get off stage and you go home and
you're frustrating you're crying at
night because you really really really
really want to do this for the rest of
your [ __ ] life you'll know it now
you'll know it you'll start putting [ __ ]
the back burner it's an addiction like
suicide at one time I was always calling
me in the back of my head and I tried to
do everything I could because I knew how
hard it was gonna be so I tried to do
everything else but with each passing
year I was like you know what I got to
do this no listen I was the type of guy
I needed to pay bills too but I also had
a love for someone I understood that the
bills were not gonna be paid yeah would
say enough that I had to do other things
yeah sighs my income yeah but that love
that love is I'm getting that love back
ever since I shot the Netflix special
and put everything in perspective for me
I've been 27 years or 26 years since
I've been doing comedy yeah every couple
years you get a new perspective and this
goes for just life itself yeah you're
not the same person you were when you
were 18 and your thought process was the
same as a person when you were 25 I love
you though 45 45 and I'm realizing that
I'm a white belt at life like I'm
starting to go what do I really know
what do I really want I'm serious what
was Steve some old doing at 21 at 21 I
was graduating college trying to figure
it out and then I wound up taking a job
with MBNA the credit card company was
terrible I was even consider stand-up at
that time I had up on the radar yes
was that the taming on the radar I
didn't think I was allowed to do
stand-up
that's the truth I thought somebody had
I thought you had to come from a special
family or you had to know somebody and I
did an open mic that's when I got bit by
the bug
I got I did like do the over mic what
made you just show up to economy I
always loved comedy to me it was the
coolest thing it was always I grew up in
a in a house or laughter kept us
together you know no matter how bad
things got we could always laugh and my
older brother was the funniest person
I've ever met my life my dad is the best
audience there is he was just died
laughing and we were one of the first
families to have cable and I remember
those HBO young comedian specials
I remember Carlin doing specials I ever
seen Richard Pryor I've never seen Eddie
Murphy delirious I mean as a little kid
because my parents are cool they're like
let him watch it and I mean I loved it
from the first I remember my parents
dropping me off when I mean I was - it's
one of my earliest memories and my dad
had tickets to go see Richard Pryor at
the Latin casino and I'm her being 2
years old going I wish I could go with
them you would too 2 2 2 I remember I
remember getting dropped off at my
grandparents house so they could babysit
us and my dad telling us because my
older brother was five telling us what
Richard Pryor did on stage when they
came to pick us up
well how funny it was that was the first
time you got up on stage well I remember
when I was in college I was too scared
to ever do anything entertainment
related but I took an elective class
where I built sets for the play that's
what I did because I kind of wanted to
see like what that world was like but I
didn't want to let anybody know I ever
wanted to do anything anything about
everything I could what did you read I
remember there was a little magazine for
actors that they sold in Philly at
certain bookstores it was called the
Ross reports was a little paper later
they come on I don't I just remember
picking up the comedy episode issue with
an interview with Mitzi shore in it I
would read I would read any biography I
could on comedians I'd watch anything on
TV related to comedy and Ira my dad took
me to go see da maré era at the funny
bone in Philly when I was 15 that was
the first time I saw a live comedy then
next time I saw a live comedy I was
touching the rafters of the Philadelphia
spectrum but
worse seats in the house we were sitting
behind one of the Flyers banners to see
Andrew Dice Clay and then the third
person I saw do stand-up comedy live
when sighs the late great John Pinette I
saw him open up for Sinatra on my 21st
birthday I went to go see Sinatra at the
sands with my dad and Pinette opened up
I never going I want to do that I didn't
tell anybody I wanted to do it but I saw
what he was doing and I'm like a
comedian gets to hang out with Sinatra
I'm like this is what I want to do or
use this that was 94 95 something like
that that's what I'd look for that right
there well he just got off the road I
met him at the comedy words Wow
I got his autograph that and then when
did you see you got on stage how old
were you guys the first time I was on
stage I think I was 22 I did an open mic
in Baltimore where I went to college and
I did like two or three of them and then
the oak and I brought all my friends and
I killed but then my friend stopped
coming after two weeks and there was
nobody there to do the open mic and they
cancelled it so then I it was the 90s
comedy was dead I never calling clubs
trying to figure out they didn't have
open mikes
or if they did have an open mic it was
once a month and then I was like I can't
I didn't have the courage to go to New
York or LA at the time so I just took a
corporate job but in the back of my
brain I always thought about it I always
thought about it and then I'd like go
through the paper and I'd see if there
was a comedy show I could go just go
watch and then I remember taking a
comedy class it was fantastic I do think
the comedy class oh my gosh I don't want
to say the guy's name but he was fair it
was Joey
I mean imagine was in Philly at like a
casting place they taught a comedy class
so this poor guy is trying to teach
comedy in Philadelphia and he he's got
like a lot of theories and stuff like
that amber this dude in the class just
getting mad at everything he saying he
goes well why should we listen to you
what makes you so funny because I'm a
professional comedian my friend because
you've never done anything funny in this
class
oh you don't think I'm funny okay all
right all right everybody we're gonna
make pretend that this is a nightclub
and I'm about to perform and he goes all
right so turn down the lights and then
you announce me
and then everybody clapped when I come
out and I eat and I'm like I couldn't
believe I was watching it and he and
everybody's clapping he comes out hey
hey how you doing I'm so-and-so I come
from a tough neighborhood
the name of my parish was Our Lady of
Mike Tyson that was his first joke and I
was like this is the guy I'm from I was
like oh this is there yeah guys those
teeth those classes yeah guys that I
stayed in the class because I felt bad
exactly I mean so those are the guys
that teach the stand I mean the guy who
taught me my stand-up class wasn't a
great great comic but he knew little
things mm-hmm well I got stuck the first
she I would call him and he'd tell me
what to do like he was good at that
stuff like don't go down there you don't
want to go over that go over there and
do that yeah look he's taught me
strategy that's good don't call that go
here because that gal see and he knows
this guy this guy this guy if you go to
Steve Simone's roomie he'll put you up
then he's got nothing else everybody
hates him because he stole that room
exactly Peas yeah he started to give you
all the political political landscape so
don't go by chicopee's he's dead go to
this guy cuz he's got six rooms and if
he likes you would you that's a whole
other side of the business that you
don't cuz you think it's just about
making people laugh yes but that's like
the least important part strategy you
know the strategies that you watch
people I mean you don't learn you watch
mm-hmm you know it's part of Mississippi
whole program was getting put you on the
doors he can watch watch watch why I
told you we were talking before we
started the podcast I how enjoyable is
to sit in the back of the store without
people shaking yeah in the talking to
you yeah we even comics when I'm
watching something the comic wants to
take it the [ __ ] away from me get the
[ __ ] away they're calling yeah I'm
enjoying watching Marc Maron I'm living
it I'm going into his [ __ ] world yeah
you want to say hello now wait I'm the
[ __ ] hallway you want me
[ __ ] all good [ __ ] right well they
want to breathe in you here with that
bad breath ah yeah leave me the [ __ ]
alone
you see I'm watching this [ __ ] guy in
pants and enjoying it and enjoy it you
should look at my eyes
you see you can see the vein from the
other side of the room it's dark what
does that tell you that vein is a Do Not
Disturb sign on a [ __ ] door
leave me the [ __ ] alone yeah hey are you
doing I'm great I was I was great the
above them yet now I've got a dolly Wang
stay the [ __ ] mind here yeah and
figure out how to drop a bomb like yeah
kisaki because when you follow a li wang
you sitting there thinking how am I
gonna get it yeah I hope she ends right
now so I got a min yes you know you
dumbass [ __ ] material yeah she throws
a lob at you in the end you can absolute
you play audience says something weird
on the way up as I got nothing right
yeah I got nothing you know you in the
original woman was built for you to try
[ __ ] you know so that's that's what
people have to understand spring
renewing the rigid million [ __ ] I'm
sitting back there hypnotized I'm
watching the best of the business just
like you are so much fun I'm watching
the best of the business whenever I get
lonely I just go down to the store watch
and I feel so blessed to be a part in
that last little seat there I told Bob
was there yeah there's [ __ ] seats this
[ __ ] thank God for Mitzi thank God
for the [ __ ] I don't really know I would
not be in LA if there was no Comedy
Store would not be here I wouldn't I
wouldn't have lasted I I want to leave
now but I can't leave this store I can
leave LA tomorrow but I can't leave the
store my man there that got brought up
broke him brought him up brought me up
my mistake
and it was Marin and Baron went up
saying he goes you know you guys are
gonna have to wait to see [ __ ] Joey
beers have a heart attack up here
whatever you know and I thought about it
when the yellow he does even matter no
no it's the truth oh you know when I go
up to the original I leave my heart that
stage and if I do have a [ __ ] heart
attack I hope it's on that stage mm-hmm
I hope it's on that [ __ ] stage anyway
you're saying I don't give a [ __ ] if it
when it comes to the store like I don't
give a [ __ ] anymore that is my home you
destroyed Oh
I've been I was wanted that was a hot
room dude I was like I can't wait to see
what Joey does look I hate a bag of
dicks in there
what night about 10 days ago on a Sunday
night I did a show I was not supposed to
be on you could I could use all the
excuses that I want mmm I just went up
there I was unprepared well my head
wasn't in it it was a Sunday night I
don't watch the 60 Minutes about Syria
Rocky 3 first time I saw clubber Lang
wearing your life lesson in it just my
head was this well up on stage and I had
friends in the audience and I just ate a
bag of dicks and I'm gonna call Lee on
the way up normally I was laughing I go
at least I have good sets in Houston he
was hanging out I go cuz I just ate a
bag of dicks in [ __ ] store and so I
know I got five good sets coming ahead
of me oh my god that's so true my god I
don't understand it even understands and
why can you be so happy because I'm
getting out of the way yes you know
understand when you doing County for two
years you're bobbing five four five
it's not fun going up but the longer you
do it the percentages go down just
remember you are gonna Bob yes expected
yes be prepared and you could only
prepared you can have your I've seen
everybody bomb in the hola everybody by
at the peak of their power oh my god I
bombed in the main room so bad two
Sundays ago but I walked out of there I
didn't even say goodbye
yeah whatever you tell me that was one
of the first pieces of advice she told
me he goes Stevie if you bought just get
out just leave get out just leave a room
get in your car to just go because if
you the whole menu would be thinking is
that your last spot right did Missy see
this yeah yes she did
Oh Tommy Missy was in the building yeah
you leave there you like I remember when
I was a young comic it's funny if I had
a good set I'd go well somebody's gonna
give me a TV show like if I had a good
set I was like yeah I should have my own
show but if I bombed I would go I gotta
quit then maybe this isn't for me and
then the wife bro yeah you gotta have
bad days absolutely and you have good
days if you get your panties in a bunch
about a bad day yeah
you're done yeah
bad down in one date will you have it
only alright you just go eat a roast
beef sandwich no this is it so I'm gonna
do the roll along with some pepper
Cheney's yesterday do what you gotta do
but you had eat your sandwich go to bed
can you wake up with this new outlook
mm-hmm sometimes got to get punched in
the face
Tuesday by that went down here and now
I'm on a different level this is what
I'm doing I'm sick and tired of PC Carly
yeah I'm say good time to judd apatow is
[ __ ] him to compile a half these
people criticized yep i watch that i am
richard pryor won't tell me central
friday night there's a new spec we're
trying to get Jennifer Jennifer briar on
either this week or next week
Wow that'd be to Friday up on that
documentary
I heard Lisa parable the priest told me
about that documentary said it was great
oh oh I was at the island my heart was
beating you know when he came back from
Africa he said he wasn't gonna use the
word [ __ ] no more Justice Richard
Pryor was a different [ __ ] level yeah
and I just decided even before I said I
don't bow on I'm going to the store to
do one thing Kerala then only because I
want that same but I said when I go on
the road for 15 minutes I want to beat
him up like I do at the store I don't
have to change my act like my little a
factory I mean I'll change it up cuz I'm
there are people's feelings no I'm going
full speed ahead
I went up our stairs yeah my rogue was
in there and I don't know what got over
me I went up there like a [ __ ] maybe
Tuesday night Tuesday night last week I
will up there and Rogan was gonna
improper he goes what are you gonna do a
lap dog I'm gonna stay here he goes
what's your infatuation Louis on with
the Konami strike I won't [ __ ] nor the
improv man yeah I want to stay and he
goes all right I'll watch it I got my
weight but maybe I'll come but you're
saying it's not watch I just told him
what made over dog I will up there like
a [ __ ] animal
when I got out of stage he's like Joey
what the [ __ ] did you say is that no
this this
I know wrong I don't know what I said I
don't care it's like they do it me no
more I'm gonna go up there
every [ __ ] that little father you
create something I start walking people
like I'm done yeah I love that I love it
it's force of nature I'm going into the
original and the main rules from now on
to walk people good I don't care what
comes out of my mouth I'm gonna put it
on a piece of paper bring it down there
and go off good and if I die so be it if
I destroy the room so be it but that's
what I'm using it for it's just too good
it's it's I have the gym that everybody
in the world I have Gold's Gym yeah we
have access to gold gym we want to be a
bodybuilder the seventies what did you
do did you stay in Philadelphia no I
packed up - you're right yeah country
you lived outside of Venice there was no
rent yeah people lived in their cars in
the car no what you live in the beach
and wait till they shoot your butt all
day you're outside [ __ ] lifting
weights I am at I have the I've had the
benefit in this life of losing a mother
being a junkie going to prison but
there's a flip side to that [ __ ] coin
and the flip side is that God put me in
a place where the best and the promise
in the world I've walked into absolutely
the world yeah the world something I
could never even imagine in my whole
[ __ ] life when I was starting I said
incredible I saw the comedy some lessons
that's his planet yeah I see Mars yes I
can relate to that we're gonna be on I
would hear people telling stories
Kinison and dice that go on Howard Stern
back in the 80s and 90s and tell stories
about late-night craziness at the Comedy
Store
I'm racing Garry Shandling on The
Tonight Show you can catch him this week
at the Comedy Store all those books I
read about comedy everything was about
the Comedy Store The Comedy Store the
Comedy Store and that song you played
the you might find yourself here I
sometimes I'm at the Comedy Store and
the hair of my arms just stands up and I
go how could a kid we could from
Delaware County Pennsylvania
wind up in the back of the Comedy Store
watching Joey Diaz destroy this room
like last night I saw you on stage and I
almost started to cry I was just like
this is it this is all I want out of
life like I'm living my life this is it
I'm at the greatest place on earth what
else do I want I don't know
join the circus if that's what the [ __ ]
and see brothers I was in it now I just
want Duke I have fall I don't want to do
specials you kill us well expect oh I
don't care about anything I just want to
go out on stage I don't [ __ ] I'm right
there with you I will [ __ ] I'm gonna
sit right there when I hear no ayay I
will put this out on a CD you have leash
up with that [ __ ] thing and I will
start the scratch again that's what I
did laughs accorded a CD last week I
don't give a [ __ ] and laugh at change
stories and I'm like this one I want to
do I don't want to do specials I don't
care I don't wanna do nothing I'd rather
put up you two clips yes I'm having a
[ __ ] blast yeah having a [ __ ]
blast you know yeah what date you got
coming up little brother dude I am done
I'm the only thing I have is I'm on a
cruise ship in April oh you come with me
and Jonah but take you somewhere in June
it's time for us to do something I would
love that
let's do something let's go [ __ ] get
think I would love to kill a
[ __ ] anyway I want to thank you
thank you and I do have a new album
coming out I'm gonna call it Jabba
what is it coming up probably within the
month I'll let you know let us know and
i retweeted thank you stuff cos I know
these guys love you they won't hey the
last time you were here was grandly and
I obviously went off the [ __ ]
reservation it was a class it was a cool
did we order sandwiches that yeah that's
a day we believe that ladies and
gentlemen $60 on three sandwiches cuz me
and [ __ ] Godzilla over here where the
[ __ ] and I thank God we have the voice
of reason here the Christian I think I
think it's like an hour for it to get
here and they were gone in six months
even lammle kept saying I want the
chicken eat Italy cause I could see two
times like he's like that girl that you
show you dicta and they cover their eyes
but keep one eye on that sleeve you want
to buy this and it's not really I'm not
hungry I'm not gonna eat I'm gonna leave
and what snow look at you go you sure a
piece of sushi because right back into
his back
[ __ ] Hawaii is he would need to check
out the chicken parm with one of those
sandwiches the sauce the sausage and
pepper sauce your purpose underling we
were too [ __ ] high
yeah when you started to fall asleep
it's like I've never seen that dog dirty
[ __ ] years again I I've never seen my
a Gorilla Biscuits those [ __ ] have a
bullet
please sure I think I had to would use
that name that was it yeah they're
strong yeah so that's it I'm done I'm
pretty much done with edibles
I just been spoken we got some new bonds
a new track for she dropped two of them
off I'm using one's the Mike Tyson I'm
keeping the other what the house I've
been smoking dope with [ __ ] ice cubes
with distilled water
oh my lungs feel tremendous I don't know
why I put this still dwelling the sleep
apnea machine I only fill it up once a
month I might as well do something with
it yeah it's just collecting dust the
[ __ ] call it makes a difference yes I
put in my yeah yeah I had to start
putting water in the happy machine man I
was waking up at 2 in the morning
[ __ ] dry I hope it smells like
[ __ ] debt and the shower wouldn't
Brown cuz I'm dehydrated I'm done I'm
done I had to start putting it [ __ ]
in there so if you have the sleep apnea
machine don't forget to refill that
[ __ ] reservoir it dries your [ __ ] out
too much and affects you later on like I
said I want to thank Steve Simone I want
to thank the [ __ ] I don't want
to thank you [ __ ] don't forget
Pittsburgh and prop this for tickets
left for the first show and all I got a
late Thursday show for April whatever we
lunch yeah April 6th all we got is
Thursday and don't forget 419 Fitzgerald
theta3 for [ __ ] 20 and then for 20
[ __ ] the paps theater in the
walk-in home but Jeffrey Dahmer come on
out and have a [ __ ] good time beside
that I want to give you a word from my
sponsors our first sponsors been with us
since day one I want to thank one all my
heart I want to give a shout out the
audit when it comes to supplements
they're there to help you one of the
best [ __ ] companies in the world you
know why I love them so much I do
business with them still because they're
one of a few companies that gives you
100% money-back guarantee you keep the
product on the Alpha brand Wow a lot of
people [ __ ] do that people do that
usually every shitty [ __ ] products
and that's how they trick it not alpha
brain not haunted not forgiving you that
type of guarantee whether it's alpha
brain whether it's the shroom tech sport
or the shroom tech immune which I
[ __ ] live on
especially when I fly on these [ __ ]
filthy planes and you're going to F what
they just gave a warning if you flew to
LAX - we saw you check yourself for the
measles good job I got the measles so
that's the [ __ ] we got to bring in
because people are one of the best don't
be [ __ ] kids vaccinate those [ __ ]
filthy kids they're filthy anyway I went
off track
my point is on it for all your
supplements all right
press Church on the way out get 10%
delivered to your house you're gonna be
happy start off with the Alpha brand the
shroom tech immune you're gonna be
[ __ ] happy the other sponsor who I
love you know why because they're always
looking out for you it's manscape calm
you know why because the worst thing in
the world is to be standing there and I
love my wife but from time to time
I gotta make a trim my nutsack hair not
my nuts I can but the hair on your
[ __ ] dick cuz it gets too dry I don't
condition my pubic hairs so it gets too
[ __ ] dry so I can I have her cut it
now I love my wife but you know what she
ain't no specialist in cuttin what if
she's listening
Maxine I got a vein you gotta go to the
hospital van bleep and [ __ ] we got I
don't need that [ __ ] that's where
[ __ ] manscape comes in uncle Joey's
here to tell you don't cut your dick off
[ __ ] oh the shufflin ends now with
manscape you could get it done without
the [ __ ] pain why because they got
precision tools for the [ __ ] nuts of
life all right the invention their
invention is the lawn mower a handheld
razor with skin safe technology so it
won't Nick or snag your ball sack you
gotta go easy on the [ __ ] tendons you
understand me this bad boy will leave
you clean smooth and pain [ __ ] free
plus it's rechargeable that's what I
liked about the best you take it on the
road it comes in its own pack
see you got em all so you get all the
nooks and crannies manscape we'll get
your bean bag looking as small as a
[ __ ] egg you understand me like
please head right now I think he
manscaped that [ __ ] the head of not
days God anyway I'm gonna let you a
little secret if you trim the hedges the
tree looks [ __ ] taller
what are you waiting for trim that
[ __ ] Cuban I grow cops cuz
[ __ ] at manscape calm you got
everything you need to make your ball
shine and keep your dick looking [ __ ]
sensationally understand me they got a
ball wipe you get one side you wipe your
ball you flip it over you stick your
finger
and cleaning around the muffler you keep
that in your glove compartment just in
case your [ __ ] boo-boo
bump into one of those [ __ ] that be
walking around from time to time you
never know if you're not prepared
nobody's gonna show up I'm saying right
or wrong anyway the perfect package
comes with a lawnmower and the safety
razor plus the crop preserver especially
formulated anti shaving deodorant so
your balls don't stink and they Reviver
for a guy like me that the nutsack smell
is beyond belief I'm over 50 a spritz
that tones and refreshes your junk to
keep it cool it shrinks it's like
putting that [ __ ] things you don't
have no wrinkles anyway my church family
the listeners of the church can get 20%
off your first order when you use old
church at manscape tom and if you order
the perfect package forget about it
don't throw in the free travel bag when
you use code Church that's manscape com
use promo code church for 20% off your
first all let me tell you something if
you're into keeping your nutsack nice
and clean and smooth if you ain't the
smacking girls in the face of your dick
the [ __ ] manscape package is for you
all right
go to manscape com use promo code church
and I'll give you 20% off your first
order other sponsor who I love to death
they make things happen you know why cuz
they put ghee this and your
[ __ ] pocket and that's my
bookie listen the first week an event
seat double a toilet is the greatest
betting event of the year whether you're
filling our brackets with Grandma or
pick a national championship predicting
the first round upsets or all the above
my bookie is the perfect home for your
March Madness fund will Zeon Williams
and his teammates cement that legacy at
Duke with the title or Camden Ginny get
past its loss to a 16 seed last last
year if you know the answers or even if
you don't my book is the place for you
to get on the [ __ ] action it's
all about action why have clean balls if
you're not gonna have no [ __ ] action
Illinois their goal is to give you the
best customer service in the business
and that's what my bookies about they've
been in business for years and the best
part about it is they pay out fast when
you win 48 hours
bad butts in your account you bet with
the best then you kick back and enjoy
March Madness like a
after you get that little [ __ ]
Chiclets missing an eyeball to come over
and lick your nuts and who's better than
you you got fresh balls you pick the
winner you're gonna wet and win some
money and you put a betting with my
people over there my bookie now what
we're gonna do is this deposit with my
bookie today and use promo code Church
and they're gonna give you a 50% signup
bonus right off the bat you're making
money with I won't show who's better
than me nobody that's promo code shirt
si-hu rch with my bookie you play you
win and you get [ __ ] paid you
understand me
don't forget Pittsburgh all I got is
Thursday night 10 o'clock
Steve Simone is coming with me in June
I'll [ __ ] surprise you [ __ ]
and the flying Jew is still doing his
thing ready to go [ __ ] he looks like
Pontius Pilate without the beard no [ __ ]
it who gives a [ __ ] I love you
[ __ ] to stay black have a great
week it's Monday morning don't let
nobody [ __ ] stop you kick this
[ __ ] mule II